the impeachment hearings from last week were
not the fireworks that we had maybe hoped
for or thought there were going to be last
week.
If I had to really sum it up, I would say
we got corroboration of a lot of stuff we
suspected and then we had one new piece of
information, which was about a phone call
between the EU ambassador Gordon Sunland and
Donald Trump, which took place while Sundland
was in a restaurant.
That phone call may have been surveilled by
Russian intelligence.
We found out, uh, and bill Taylor's staffer
overheard that phone call.
That call has since been corroborated.
It happened.
That's part of what we now have more information
relating to.
Things changed this week.
Yesterday's testimony was much different and
it was very devastating to the Trump narrative.
Now, whether it will do anything as another
question we've already discussed, but let's
talk about the substance.
We had Lieutenant Colonel Alexander Veneman
credible, clearly trustworthy, careful not
to say more than what he can defend with facts
and personal knowledge.
Still, they were smearing and active duty
member of the military because they didn't
like what he said, and we'll get to that a
little bit later.
Every witness yesterday confirmed a part of
the case against Trump.
Trump used foreign policy for his reelection
campaign benefit.
He used military aid to try to get campaign
favors through uh, getting Biden smeared.
It was an explorative act of bribery.
Yesterday we had Lieutenant Colonel Veneman
and Jennifer Williams who are now firsthand
witnesses to the July 25 phone call.
Remember, Republicans previously complaining
everything's hearsay.
Nobody has firsthand knowledge that changed
yesterday I had told you the July 25 phone
call is not the whole story.
You can't just look at that to determine if
there was bribery.
That was likely the conclusion to a story
that started earlier with negotiations and
phone calls and emails.
And we confirmed that today because ambassador
Gordon Sunland showed up and threw everyone
under the bus.
The, we were live streaming and the chat tripled
in speed on our YouTube channel when Sunland
started speaking because we didn't know if
Sundland was going to play the, I don't remember,
I plead the fifth game or if he would show
up and effectively completely turn on the
president of the United States.
And he turned big time and Republicans panicked
and try to mitigate what Sunland said.
But Sunland said everybody knew what was going
on.
There were emails involving the national security
council.
Rudy Giuliani was having conversations and
text messages.
The president knew what was going on.
Sunland made clear that the idea that you
know, maybe you could make the case that something
was implied, but we don't really know.
Sunland says, and he has the records to back
it up.
Everybody knew what the deal was.
This was money in exchange for smears meeting
in exchange for public press conference about
investigations Sunland through everyone under
the bus, so that is devastating to Donald
Trump.
Kurt Volker amended prior testimony also in
a way that was damaging to Trump.
He says, listen, I learned a lot more since
my initial testimony and I have much more
to say.
Even Trump's supposedly strongest witness.
Volcker said Bidens and honorable man, and
we hold him in high regard.
There is no basis to the conspiracies that
Trump has been pushing.
So on the substance, this has been particularly
today with Sunland, extraordinarily devastating.
Meanwhile, all Republicans can try to do,
to slow it down is be boring.
Go into tangential stories about Hunter Biden
or other irrelevant details.
Try to attack character, assassinate the witnesses
and the real problem.
And ultimately, this is why nothing may quote
happen as we're talking about in terms of
making things happen.
Too many Trump supporters either don't understand
the severity of this and maybe they never
will, uh, or they, uh, have actually fallen
for the very weak talking points of Republicans.
The goal would be if even some of the Trumpists
can see what's going on, see what went down
and be pulled into the light by each one of
these hearings.
Then it's a good thing.
And we'll of course be following all of them.
All of the live streams that youtube.com/the
David Pakman show.